foreign
[Music]
right in
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and I find myself
[Music]
cause I'm wasted oh I wasted again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
myself another bottle and crawl right in
[Music]
I look back on all the women I've known
and all I've ever done was trying to
show but man they thought they found a
side of me but I'm my own words
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
right in
[Music]
baby
[Music]
baby's getting up
I think I just don't give a [ __ ]
close it up on these rocks I stay where
are my best friends
[Music]
and I'm by myself
[Music]
again
[Applause]
[Music]
by myself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and I just found myself another bottle
and crawl right in
I look back on all the women I've known
and all I've ever done was tried to show
but man they thought they found a side
of me but I'm my own words
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
right in
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
right in
cause I'm wasted
oh I wasted a girl
myself
[Music]
by myself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and I just found myself another bottle
and crawl right in
I look back on all the women I've known
and all I've ever done was tried to show
but man they thought they found a side
of me
[Music]
and I'm wasted but I'm wasted a girl
[Music]
and fall right in
foreign
[Music]
again
[Music]
and I'll just find myself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a little pressure
oh yes
guys forcing all the social media
Instagram Twitter Facebook Francisca
Foster constant kissing trigger pod
follow us all depends on kill it already
come on follow us follow us follow us
hello beautiful bigots bigger testers
and of course the cute little bigotini
welcome one welcome all we have a
cracking show for you today whether you
love football or you hate football we're
going to do an hour before the game uh
so everybody can enjoy themselves and
then we'll uh encourage you to go watch
the game and watch it ourselves
absolutely this is a pre-match raw we've
got so much good news from across the
globe to talk about we can't wait
yeah that is true well whatever you're
doing right stay here stay here don't go
anywhere and we are going to talk about
all things around the world I was going
to say politics Renee but it's not just
politics it's culture it's sport It's
Entertainment I mean it's philosophy
yeah a bit of [ __ ] culture mate it's
Birds isn't it birds in there all that
there's birds in there uh Lee Barber
says FF looks healthy WTF we've both got
uh stage makeup on it yeah yeah that's
it so I have actually got staged makeup
I think we've got quite good at applying
the Old Stage mate yeah I mean I do
looks like slightly trumping and a
little bit orange but birds love it no
don't they don't have types of birds
yeah certain types of birds the ones you
have to pay yeah
I mean come on legitimate joke yeah
fantastic it obviously is a joke because
we haven't done a census amongst them no
we haven't uh
the reason Francis is looking healthy is
the fact that we are both wearing makeup
of Francis why are we both wearing
makeup the reason we're making we're
wearing makeup is because we identify as
women
isn't it no no it's because we
interviewed Dr J batter
oh lovely didn't [ __ ] about Dr Jay he
went straight in two feet so we talked
about everything didn't we uh Francis
but we have
the day yeah from Laura smart yeah what
did she say well you've got to put the
flat cap on me oh
[ __ ] him first comment of day yeah oh
yes you remember she's a monkey hanger
she's a [ __ ] monkey on your man no
she's not she's a Geordie anyway this is
what she says uh she says uh whatever
whatever happened to Brandon why do you
put that oh oh [ __ ] hell yes [ __ ]
webam to francis's boobs is he
de-transitioning he's on the key to the
ninja little slacker he's doing very
well I'm on the cage I will ask Randy I
was basically I'm just not eating
massive bowls of pasta anymore and so
apparently there's some issue with the
sound
it's just Frozen a couple of times we'll
just keep an eye on it okay so Anton's
keeping an eye on it by which he means
he doesn't know what the problem is and
he couldn't give a [ __ ] yeah and he's
just
gonna scratched and and now videos
hiccuping as well yeah okay great uh but
yeah so I'm I'm not eating massive bowls
of pasta I'm trying to eat healthily I'm
going to the gym three or four times a
week it's [ __ ] hell on Earth do you
know what I'm not I'm not a Chinese
Takeaway in at least a few days
desire for some kind of record for you
man yeah you haven't had a takeaway for
a couple of days yeah see Francis even
when you're not fat I mean even when
you're not fat you're still deep inside
a fat little [ __ ]
um that's where you are I am you can't
help it can you I am you know it's I'm
not one of those I'll always be like one
of those alcoholics you know what I mean
you've always got the alcoholic in your
mate it's me I've just just love a bit
of carb
just love a bit of carb mate
so there we go
um but I mean not everyone's on board
with your weight loss program well what
about the kitchen says don't lose too
much weight FF you'll get too skinny
he's quite far away from getting too
skinny He's Just Not That fat anymore
well I've got I think I've got about
four kilos to go and then I've got I'm
in my BMI
what do you mean you're in your BMI well
I'm in my car you don't just get it I'm
in my BMI mate I'm in the healthy range
of BMI you mean you're on the very far
upper range of of healthy no I mean I
mean yeah yeah so you're basically one
one gram of being a fat country yeah
exactly but
that's your objective is it yeah that is
my [ __ ] objective mate and once I do
it once I get in my BMI I'm going to
celebrate with some Capital support
groups of course you are of course iron
mate mate you're making me hungry stop
it I don't like it do you remember we
went for that Chinese with one of our
supporters oh Ricky the grand as well
yeah that was [ __ ] great wasn't it
Francis we're we're entertaining people
not just talking about meals that you
enjoy what
you want to say that you can't eat
anymore because you don't want to be a
fat [ __ ] yeah it was grumpy I mean
seriously those were the glory of those
mate see this is what this is how you
know he's gonna balloon back up yeah
because yeah yeah he he he's lost the
way but he hasn't lost the fact cut
instead
no I love Capital Paul it's my anthem
when he was like I'm a vegetarian
I care about animals me foreign
anyway let's find out what the beautiful
bigots are all saying we've got a big
paypalio coming in as well but let's
start with the Super Chat Anton
oh yeah he's [ __ ] up north I haven't
worked in 12 years come watch tonight as
I'm working don't [ __ ] lie to me Jim
I know your game but I've said it on
locals now say it again football is shot
it's a minji's name minji's game not
natural don't agree with it carry on
[ __ ] bollocks all right keep going
mate I'm just pulling up the paypaliers
uh Vanessa C she said 55 see
it here you go oh yes yes
certificate yeah freezing at the bus
stop glad you are the early boys to
mourn my biggest heart much love from a
city everything in London oh she's in
London he's in London yes oh yes very
good very good thank you
let's get some rainbow Flags in the chat
because ebl who's from Brighton not this
Anton not baby blue sky we'll come back
to this in a second obviously because we
love baby blue sky but I was reading
this one out e Emmy bakalana sent us a
hundred quid 100 knickers so let's
pretend we are the last leg and fill the
chat with rainbows yeah you know trans
Pride flags and whatever because that's
what Brian's all about it is she says hi
guys this is a bit of a long post so
feel free not to read it all come on ebl
yeah we're gonna do it we love you ebl
we know you're a bird you're gonna bang
on for a bit it's fine it says in the
last few years you've both taken Knox
from within and without comedy and had
some real crap thrown your way you've
also had some real turnips and wins I
know you you joke that birds love it and
birds love trans but I want to say how
much I appreciate you having guests like
Kathleen stock Marcus Evans uh Graham
Lincoln Posey Colin Wright Etc who've
been working to crack the hold of gender
we're on Society for all your
problematic banter you've also been
standing up for Birds children and all
the gays when so many have been throwing
us all under the bus so thank you both
please keep making us laugh and Making
burgers out of all the sacred cows ebl
gets in like nobody else and we're gonna
keep serving up the red meat for the
birds we've got Helen Joyce coming on
soon as we've got joy see she's coming
on now obviously you know we're joking
around and stuff but we Francis and I
from from early on in doing the show
felt that it was really really important
uh to talk about these issues because
you know Francis with his background as
a teacher not that many of you knew that
yeah no you used to teach in school yeah
uh until he was you know until the court
case yeah exactly um you know we've
always innocent no not guilty yeah don't
confuse the two because it's not the
same thing yeah
um we always felt it was very important
uh that these issues where children are
being harmed get addressed and there are
other subjects as well where we've
always felt that it's really important
that they continue to get covered until
that issue gets resolved in one way or
another so we're going to carry on doing
that and uh when new issues will pop up
which of course they will we're going to
tackle them as well that that's that's
the mission statement of trigonometry
absolutely and price as well
I don't like and neither does constantly
neither does Anton anyone going you
can't talk about this you have to talk
about no I live in a western liberal
democracy I'll talk about whatever I
[ __ ] want that's what you thought
mate exactly stay home
yeah uh Jay battachary is a great
interview you're going to want to watch
that when it comes out it's very very
very good yeah uh but anyway Anton what
was Baby Blue Sky saying let's pull that
up huh
oh she's a [ __ ] northerner as well
he's giving me a life savings having a
few unfiltered Northern pints tonight
have a grand weekend kknff thank you
very much baby blue sky we will thank
you my darling although of course we do
have another brilliant role coming
tomorrow but anyway baby blue sky thank
you so much uh Silas Larson there is the
Viking helmet yeah it says Anton must be
hogging the band which was the webcam
girl what webcam girl no he's not no
he's not he's not into webcams are you
Anton no he just he just he just looks
at videos of warm-ups from Slovenian
gymnastics yeah and sprinters and stuff
yeah that's what he does he's a big fan
of the Portuguese under 23 poll voting
he's a man of Exquisite taste yeah and
great principle yeah exactly
nice and toned and slender he does
could say he likes his meat organic yeah
he does and young anyway
the thing is he's got like a bird now as
well yeah right she doesn't watch
anymore this year Anton no no
for this reason that we would rinse you
I remember one world
we were talking about the subject of uh
of breasts and and I asked you the
question do you bury your head in them
and Shout the words mummy
and she was watching I mean that made
the conversation we're still getting
complaints about audio and video uh
you don't know what he says he doesn't
know what to do but but it's not that
bad yeah it sounds to me like he doesn't
know what to do and it is quite bad yeah
that's what I'm getting out of this yeah
Anton have you got anything open is
Dropbox open and uploading or anything
like that
really yeah
oh well okay we're just gonna have to
make do guys for it's it's an hour show
today maybe we both come off the Wi-Fi
it's nothing to do with that mate we've
got very good internet here so there's
nothing to do with that uh Savoy 1984
with a 449. I'll be amazed if anybody
knows who he is but happy birthday John
Lara Cory Laura Laura Cott laraquette I
I don't know who that is who's John
Larroquette I don't know he's probably
some nonso Nazi pedophile probably but
Anton is busy Googling him ruining his
web search yeah and history
someone says the audio is just choppy at
times first world problems are you
sitting on a microphone no no you're not
is it both of us
okay John Bernard larica is an American
actor okay cool well as long as he's not
a Peter we're not [ __ ] interested
right yeah exactly
1984. I appreciate it nice
solving Mark with a 20 American dollars
yeah does Dexter's Texas barbecue count
is keto he wasn't on the keto back then
he was making all three of us Fat Mike I
look back at my but towards the end of
that trip we did not look well no we
didn't thanks to you he's dragging us to
every [ __ ] restaurant in sight mate
the content was excellent people loved
it you're not doing that again mate
we're talking about next time we go to
America yeah early next year yeah you're
going to have salad no twice a day what
about in Texas barbecue well we'll do
that once
you can't do this and you can have the
coleslaw get [ __ ]
mate we're not we're not making the same
mistakes again what do you mean the same
mistakes those were glorious victories
you just said we looked Unwell by the
end of a trip and it wasn't like it was
a three month trip no it wasn't it was
uh it was two weeks 18 days yeah it was
18 days and in 18 days you made all
three of us nearly die
Phantom was bit you were you were you
pink weren't you but Peak fat yeah he
loved it no he didn't yeah he didn't
love it not by the end he barely made it
home
uh so then Mike thank you for the twenty
dollars
in the rain there you go oh yes because
you can take the fit off the go
you can't take the Gaucho to living his
new identity without bitter Hill yes
it's true thank you Joseph
thank you very much I appreciate it nice
uh Silas Larson was a two dollars more
he says would you rather be a gay bird
or a fat turkey
a gay bird or a fat turkey
you can't get it mate I I don't why why
would you want to be a fat turkey
I mean they're all fat yeah
turkeys are quite fun they are quite
even though the meat is lean but they
look fat yeah anyway next
I never said like you Jolly Roger uh who
I believe is German ah no no don't don't
put the naughty hat on okay he's just
German okay he's just German he says as
a German I accepted that we will never
win a World War but I am afraid that the
football team will never win the world
cup either
not Germany always going to have a
chance on there actually believe it or
not this isn't actually an artsy helmet
it is an East German one
it's got from Checkpoint Charlie
well those are those are really moral
and upstanding citizens of the world
weren't they well I mean they were left
wing weren't they so they were
uh thank you Jolly Roger much
appreciated uh box head with a Fiverr oh
Dublin's action great victory for Iran
today
[Applause]
a very handsome Squad too yeah all the
birds ashaka was banging on about how
fit the guys are in their ranting yeah
they all look like pretty handsome
actually and they want fresh trims do
you know the thing is as well you know
what makes them kind of attractive is
they've they're all [ __ ] Brave
imagine growing up in Iran living under
that regime you go and play for the
Iranian football team your first match
in a world cup and you don't Sing the
anthem you basically give two fingers to
a [ __ ] murderous regime
they're good boys and they beat the
Welsh too now and you know what they
[ __ ] deserved it well done to Iran
thanks Buck said appreciate the Fiverr
uh CRS with the 15 quinces the football
is coming home also Francis is looking
as good as ever I am indeed thank you
Bosch there we go well Francis shall we
talk about English fans going over to
Qatar right and sharing a bit of British
culture yeah be a banter what's wrong
with it let's have a look at the story
number one Anton
there we go we can't see the title mate
so you're gonna have to scroll down
right now that ladies and gentlemen is a
crusader outfit yeah uh Qatar bans
Crusaders costumes and they're plastic
swords
it's political now for those of you
you don't know English fans often wear
uh you know like a fake chain mail with
the Crusaders some symbolism on it yeah
when they go abroad especially uh to
support the team exactly they like to do
in Muslim countries as well because it
you know it brings people together
Legends anyway let's find out what the
guitarist couldn't handle the banter
apparently uh four nations have been
invaded by the English dressing Crusader
uniforms
for more than a thousand years although
these days their swords are made of
plastics but plastic sorry they are no
more welcome in Qatar England supporters
have been banned before tonight's World
Cup match against the US from dressing
as Christian Invaders after it was ruled
offensive to Muslims fans of Theresa St
George who is traditionally depicted as
a crusader Knight and matches for at
least 20 years but FIFA have said they
they are inappropriate in Qatar the
first Islamic country to host a
tournament we will we will Stone some
games for you some gays for you they
went on to have yeah two fans were
turned away from England's opening game
against Iran on Monday before handing in
their swords and shields several others
dressed as Crusaders were in the crowd
there you go there you go
uh FIFA said it strives to create a
discrimination-free environment really
to promote diversity across the
organization really in all of its
activities and events unless you're gay
in which case get [ __ ] because Abdul
doesn't want you it added Crusader
costumes in the Arab context can be
offensive to Muslims that is why
anti-discrimination colleagues ask fans
to wear things inside out or change
dress
Gareth southcote the manager said that
the captain hariff came would be fit for
the US game after suffering an ankle
knock against Iran imagines Harry Kane
came out dressed as a crusader that
would have been brilliant he also said
that the Prince of Wales had told the
squad to focus on football not social
media commentary FIFA has been
criticized for Banning the captains of
seven European teams including England
and Wales from wearing rainbow ambits to
promote LGBT equality guidelines drawn
up by FIFA ahead of the tournaments they
there should be no restriction on
clothing for women or men Beyond
internationally accepted etiquette where
exactly stop
exactly you filthy [ __ ] put him away
before you start tempting us to touch
you anyway kick it out you've said that
before ma'am yeah exactly sounded
rehearsed it does sound it just kind of
flows naturally off the tongue yeah I
said it outside the mosque mate got a
round of applause uh kick it out which
campaigns Against Racism and football
said we would have we had why we would
advise fans who were attending the FIFA
World Cup matches that certain attires
such as fancy dress costumes
representing Knights or Crusaders may
not be welcomed in Qatar and other
Islamic countries foreign office travel
advice issued before the tournament
expressed that fans should familiarize
themselves with local customs and we
would encourage fans to take this
approach yeah
uh Iman Atta uh director of tell Mama
sounds like a snitching organ yeah he
does a UK project monitoring
islamophobia said our fans should be
mindful that there are things that may
cause offense to Qatari citizens such as
openly wearing such as openly drinking
wearing historical Crusader Knights
Templar outfits being gay questioning
the regime doing any manner of things
that it would be accepted anywhere in
the world but condemns you as an Infidel
dog Pig in our country pig dog pig dog
is the correct term yeah that's it well
there we go mate uh would you go to
Qatar dressed as a crusader
do you know what I've pissed off so many
people why shouldn't I go and piss off
the Muslim world
um
do you know what I mean I do uh Francis
talk to them for a second I'm going to
go and see if I can help him
yeah
stop shouting mate oh well me I don't
Shout
for some reason when Anton when Francis
shout and won one of us shouts so we
will whisper for you we'll whisper
seductively in your ear blind treat you
like the dirty little princesses you are
mate could you keep your fantasy Talk
inside your head
this is just like the sort of [ __ ] you
see you say when you are like sitting
there on your own in your little flat
yeah whatever missing yeah this is great
chat mate they love it there's nothing
great about it they do they love women
are going to be switching off listen
there is a reason why roads have a
predominantly female fan base and it's
me and my
Saucy little chat you know what I mean
Ali Snyder who let's be honest she's
very nice woman but she is weird yeah
she says yes please FF there you go I
mean Ali it's not natural what's wrong
with you the birds have spoken mate they
love it she says whisper sweet bigotrys
in our ears yeah exactly she's put a
little Emoji with like the tongue out as
well Ali you're weird
get help
you need help
I'm telling you
that's what they come for
that and the chat about Capital spare
ribs next
and we've got another Super Chat no no
Super Chat so there we go Super Chat uh
there we go
ASW with a tenor well done guys the
Erasure of child safeguiding is an
emergency a couple of years ago I
scoffed when my problematic mate said
legal pedophilia is where it's all
heading but did you see the Balenciaga
ad I actually haven't you have yes I
have tell me about it uh they but they
basically see the I have I don't
understand why people are doing this I
really don't understand why people think
it's acceptable to sexualize children
and try and make it mainstream so
basically you had these kids with these
bondage style teddies
and these kids were like four years old
in these ads and they were holding
things with but you know bondage style
teddies and then there was a piece of
paper written I uh with with a memo and
it had some weird stuff on it which I
can't remember off the top of my head
because I'm not gonna remember there's
bondage teddies yeah
do you know what maybe the Qatar is all
right man you know what I mean I just
who who thinks like this who thinks he
does
but I know they think like that but my
point is like the people actioning these
ads and going you know what this is a
great idea we've got oh we've got a
fashion house and we sell our overpriced
goods for whatever a two billion percent
markup we make [ __ ] tons of cash no
that's not enough it's not enough that I
I make a suitcase for three quid and
charge you 10 grand for it you know what
else I want to do I also want to shove a
pedo message down your throat
see you disagree with me about the death
penalty but you have to admit there are
cases where it's appropriate absolutely
there you go yeah ASW thank you very
much for the tenant much appreciated
it's not Anton we've got way more Super
chats and paypals uh
yeah yeah you knock yourself out oh yeah
yeah I did I have
oh yes the Big Boy hat is coming out oh
yeah yeah I care about ball is in the
back of the Met not clinging together
like an ornamental wind chime too many
distractions
also John Lyle was average at best it
was John Lyle
I don't know hello mate uh Anton don't
worry about it uh I'll fight you naked
uh says uh with a with eight quid on
PayPal thank you uh for that says it's
unconscionable to remind us of getting
our asses kicked a thousand years ago
yes that's hands and feet sticking up
out of the foundation yes that smell is
exactly what you think here's a billion
dollars shut the [ __ ] up yep I think
he's suggesting that maybe what the
qataris are saying yeah uh okay cool
let's catch up on some more Super chats
CRS I'll be francis's dirty little
princess there you go mate
you're all mentally ill get help
yourself save yourselves while you still
can it's too late you've got the virus
m f Damien with a five dollars says uh
what does he say he says
I'd take a property much love
thank you or poopity maybe
I take a puberty much love thank you
very much and some people are saying I'm
very quiet this is not natural
okay
it's getting a bit feisty yeah yeah yes
he's getting a bit faster I said Anton
people are saying I'm very quiet he said
yeah I'm reading all the comments yeah
spineless Larson let's have let's have
the Viking ahead please oh yeah so we
have some Viking hat oh yeah FF looks
fell for one day and it goes to his head
mate you do look like the most pathetic
Viking in the history of Vikings
yeah the the Viking that you know you'd
be safe around
mate after your comments tonight I'm not
sure anyone can be safe around you who
are you talking about Dad you do it or
whatever it was you said disgusting
right that's what they like
they like a bit of sauce
oh yeah so it looks very dishes
Sweden is very good very good Michael
whatever his name is Michael I cannot
see shaktus says appreciate you bigots
uh thank you very much Mikhail we
appreciate you as well we appreciate you
all yeah uh Kathy kittson says yeah but
we know Francis wouldn't do anything
yeah you haven't met France you haven't
seen see you this is the thing you none
of you understand right because you only
see performance for answers you only see
on stage Francis you only see on screen
Francis you've never seen what this man
is capable of you've never sat around a
dinner table and watched things
disappear it's like a blue whale no
you've ever seen those massive like
documentaries where the whale opens and
like half the ocean just goes in yeah
that's what he's capable of right so you
don't know you you you don't understand
what you're dealing with here
I'll tell you what David Fuller was the
worst because we were having the Chinese
he came round we said to him David do
you want some football did you want some
football do you want some food he said
no I don't Kathy says KK is so cruel how
am I cruel thank you thank you okay
explain to me how am I cruel right
because have I ever taken away your
spare ribs like David Fuller I've ever
done no he did took away my duck get it
right right have I ever taken away your
duck no no right I respect that's why
David putter is banned from trigonometry
correct right I've never pulled food out
of his mouth right
never done that so don't call me cruel
I'm fair I'm harsh but I'm Fair Kathy
unbelievable
anyone who let's see what the other
bigger turini are saying
we've got no Super Chat so look we've
got loads of stuff to talk about today
loads and loads and loads uh let's talk
about a great man let's talk about the
best type of bloke let's talk about
Ayatollah Khomeini what a good guy there
he is look at him well look man he's
wearing masks staying safe yeah he's
protecting with the Iranian NHS yep you
know he is I mean he's doing what looks
to be a rather problematic gesture yeah
it is uh Ayatollah Khomeini mocked for
saying Iran has new cancer cure
overhyped claims including boasts of
hypersonic missiles suggests the supreme
leader feels growing in security after
Nationwide protests well we do in fact
have a fantastic episode with Ali and
Sari coming out about this uh on
Wednesday uh but let's read the article
Francis Iran's supreme leader has been
ridiculed for claiming the country has
developed a cure for blood cancer the
world's largest telescope and a new
Hypersonic missile Iran's clerical
regime may be facing the boldest
challenge to its rule since the 1979
Revolution but Ayatollah Ali kamini
issued a statement on Wednesday evening
that claimed Iranian scientists and
experts have done great work during
these few weeks of rights in the country
he used his English Twitter account to
announce scroll down please well he's
allowed a Twitter account but someone
who criticized masking and mask mandates
isn't easy yeah these claims should we
read what is it yeah yeah let's let's
read what he said let's read what the
great man said we we needed we need the
turbine by the way for Iranian accent
yeah Iranian scientists and experts have
done great work during these few weeks
of rides in the country developing new
cure for blood cancer unveiling one of
the world's largest telescopes unveiling
a new Hypersonic missile and launching
an Iranian run Refinery outside the
country as well as destroying Israel
forever yes
disgusting uh these claims Drew
immediate scrutiny for being a load of
made-up bollocks with two Twitter users
questioning when the account was a
parody while the new 3.4 meter medium
class optical telescope of the Iranian
National Observatory on Mount gagash in
Central Maine in car gas in central Iran
is large there are at least 40 bigger
facilities worldwide and when the
president's office for Science and
Technology announced an Iranian
developed gene therapy for cancer last
week it said it was a copy of a method
already in production by two
multinational companies not a new
treatment as for the Revolutionary God
Aerospace forces claim earlier this
month that it had successfully developed
a Hypersonic missile the Pentagon later
said it would skip the colbie's claims
while the claims by the Supreme Leader
may have been overhyped his motivations
reveal a deep insecurity in the face of
Nationwide protest these advancements
these advancements increase the state's
Authority and strength he said the enemy
the evil American capitalist pig dogs
won't dare to bother you if you increase
your Authority and strength such
advancements will make us
self-sufficient and strong
uh for over a decade the supreme leader
I love the fact he's not just a leader
he's a super supreme leader leader
Supreme right exactly it comes with a
portion of chips on the side yeah it's
spoken of the need for a resistance
able to counteract the effect of Western
sanctions by making Iran less reliant on
the global economy and foreign
technology but with ongoing protests
representing an internal challenge to
the Islamic Republic the 83 year old man
he's all done Biden no he's probably
better Nick than by this probably I mean
that's not hard has characterized the
Nationwide movement as a western and
Israeli of course yeah the Jews and the
Americans they've done yeah yeah keep
scrolling Iranian security forces have
responded violently to protesters really
there's a surprise mate uh with rights
groups counseling over 400 dead and
dated detainees speaking of torture and
sexual violence in detention uh that led
to the UN Human Rights Council voting on
Thursday in favor of holding a high
level internal investigation into
violations in relation to the protest
Volker Turk the rights bodies High
Commissioner said Iran faced a fully
fled human rights crisis with 14 000
people arrested including children
Khadija Karimi tehran's representative
of the Geneva talks accused the western
states of using the Rights Council to
Target Iran a move she called appalling
and disgraceful we kill who we want
exactly on Thursday Ali bargari Kearney
the deputy Minister of Foreign Affairs
said Iran has formed his own panel to
investigate deaths in recent protests
which will be incredibly yeah he'll
probably be almost as objective as the
government's covet inquiry in this
country absolutely he added that about
50 police have died and hundreds have
been injured in their unrest the first
official figure for deaths among
Security Forces there we go because
they're good boys and you know what
they're doing their best aren't they
well it's suppressing the protest yeah
thank you they're doing their best
they're trying their best they're trying
their hardest you know look mate someone
someone has got to make sure women wear
the right clothes absolutely you can't
it's not going to be me and you no
because we're filthy evil Western
capitalist pig dogs right and infidels
yeah right those boys they're gonna make
sure you know and I mean look and I'm
not gonna lie you walk around Brighton
on a Saturday night yeah who doesn't
fancy a bit of a supreme leader coming
in and sorting the south of course you
know you go down to Croydon on a
Saturday night yeah but you know exactly
it needs one of those big role models to
come in and go away Stacy look at your
skirt you are you are insulting the
great nation of Iran put it away well
first come in my limo then put it away
then put it away yes this is discovered
we need a [ __ ] morality place in
Croydon
wait don't mate it's a [ __ ] disgrace
we need a morality police is being a
supreme leader for the day yeah I do I
do I tell you what if I'm a supreme
leader for a day there'd be a lot
there'll be a lot in this country have
[ __ ] changed I mean the population
would go down by about five million if I
was supreme leader yeah uh just from all
the hangings yeah and the beatings
which is yeah I'm not into beatings well
you know into the beatings no no just
you know clean keep it clean keep it
clean keep it clinical yeah exactly uh
Anton let's find out what the beautiful
bigots are saying and then we're going
to get your predictions for the game
tonight scandi flick scandi flickiest
with the two pounds and a Russian car
thank you very much for that I
appreciate it box said with another
fiver best of luck tonight England that
hurt me to say uh though I have a
feeling the USA may be a tough one I'm
liking this world cup so far I'm gonna
be honest with you I think uh it's not
gonna be as easy as people are
predicting a USA have got some good
players uh they have got they're very
well organized they're very well you're
starting to sound like a football
manager yeah they've got some good lads
we've got some good lads yeah
it'll be a tough game we'll see what
happens exactly it's all over the Welsh
there's [ __ ]
uh all right so Anton prediction for
tonight
for one England optimistic he's just not
used to watching a good football team oh
right
what about you mate I think it's going
to be 2-1 England
I haven't followed either of the team so
I have no idea of what what the result
is going to be
um
I think it's going to be a draw there
you go I'm going to predict the draw
there we go I'll probably be wrong
though thanks Boxhead appreciate the
Fiverr
Craig Sweeney also watching the build up
for the game but right now why talk
about football when we can talk about
LGBT bollocks instead well said mate go
England Pride correct let's get some
pride in there let's talk they were
banging on about bolsonaro the other day
did you did you hear this they basically
had a long discussion about how Neymar
voted for bolsonaro and how evil he is
oh yeah there's loads of foreign
yeah but they were talking about it in
coverage of the game
since when does anyone care what a
footballer voted
thanks Craig appreciate it Go England
Pride indeed Kim
jong-unit isn't supreme leader I am the
only supreme leader he also went to
Glasgow Caledonian University no joke
no wonder he's an authoritarian mate
have you seen the SNP yeah exactly
thanks Kim Jong-un appreciate it
um
says what is the one thing we're not
talking about the coordinated to take on
the global food system by wef and Bill
Gates
marvelous thanks Joseph Eason appreciate
it Frank Booth sadly LGBT protests at
the World Cup are a risk how safe would
a pretty boy like Francis be in a Qatari
prison Gary Neville should be fine
though
I reckon Francis would get on great in
the qataria president do you think so
yeah I'd lost about three minutes before
converting to Islam yeah
I get one of those wispy little beards
yeah a little the little white hat the
little white hat I'll get it almost I'd
come out as your Mohammed Akbar and you
can and you can Channel your
keto-induced anger yeah at the infidels
yeah exactly I have said this before and
I I don't I'm sure it's controversial
out there in the big bad world but here
on trigonometry rule I mean you've got
to admit I just think a lot of Islamic
fundamentalism is a problem with Ramadan
yeah you don't eat for a month you're
gonna get a bit fundamentalist you're
gonna get [ __ ] angry you know and
here's the point you know and you look
at them and you look at you know what
people the white people convert to
winslam and fundamentalist Islam they're
all gingers they're all gingers because
they're [ __ ] angry yeah because no
one gives them any respect they're in a
press minority they don't get any they
you know and no one cares about their
pride and they're like what your
[ __ ] I'm gonna go to the big dog
right I'm gonna convert and then I'm
gonna come and [ __ ] blow you up
yeah I've never heard him called the big
dog before no I'm sure the Muslims will
appreciate that mate uh thank you Frank
Booth we appreciate it uh Dustin gueva
with the five it says hi guys long time
no chat looking forward to Stafford FF
thank you very much Dustin I'm coming to
Stafford on the 21st Leicester on the
20th of December Francis foster.co.uk
Lil coz will also be there go and check
out there's still tickets available it's
going to be great uh thank you Dustin
gueva appreciate it practiceaurus Rex
for the 449 says FFF was leader for a
day he would let all the brown birds in
mate to be honest with you they're all
they're letting all the brown birds in
anyway so we're fine but I would have
done it all right I would just let them
in if it was a man I'd be like no sorry
mate [ __ ] off
you darling front of the queue
you got a kid no thank you
disgusting
thank you very much Brontosaurus Rex
Minecraft Jade to the B to the mother
loving p is so right about us all being
capable of some pretty nasty stuff
also doesn't bolsonaro sound like a
pasta sauce [ __ ] me don't think
[ __ ] off that was said just for you
wouldn't it yeah uh Susanna with the
five pound says FF Don doons of AK asks
you to just let your hidden fantasies
out of your head it's so much fun to
listen keep going
right you need Francis you know there
used to be a time when comedians used to
have a go at us and they would say that
we've got a very problematic audience of
very problematic people
maybe they were right I I I do think
some of them have got serious you know
yeah serious issues you know what like
especially the birds I mean there's
something not right
do you know uh during my shows it has
been commented on the number of ladies
who uh come to the show thank you ladies
who come and enjoy the show yeah they're
mostly turfs y'all know they're most
people they just think you're a
de-transitioner yeah exactly in your
corner yeah exactly they're like he's
one of us huh foreign
we can get you we can get you
compensation for that Top surgery yeah
the blue says seeing more and more
Ukraine car plates in our little tourist
town on the Costa Blanca gave one a
smile and thumbs up or solidarity today
and then I saw another one on a [ __ ]
Bentley not sure what to think now says
more about me or what
I mean there's probably like I don't
know 50 people in Ukraine have a Bentley
and I'm sure they would have been the
ones that got out it's probably Andre
sevchenko mate driving about I don't
know how representative that is of of
the average Ukrainian well I do know not
at all uh Kathy says what's wrong with
us trigger Birds I I don't know but
something is
you know what I mean a beautiful
princess don't ever change
and finish your car says KK and FF are
both very handsome boys thank you there
we go all right
um
oh we've got a few more okay let's do
that
uh problematic Cruiser oh my God
how you doing
he says do you think the us could beat
Everton ask him for a friend
mate I think could talk about [ __ ]
Everton
mate we've got we've got to spend the
evening why are you riling him up
and it moves do you want to do this one
get get you you get your cowboy hat on
mate yeah oh yeah right who was the
better shot at range it looked like
Francis was a little nervous with the
pistol uh I I think it's fair to say he
was very nervous with the pistol were
you able to take the lower receiver with
you uh no we didn't take the lower
receiver with us uh who was the best the
best shot was actually Anton yeah he was
uh I think I was saying I did pretty
well and Francis did very well at
shooting the Target in the head when he
was aiming for the chest just a headshot
mate [ __ ] just did it
Seb was good as well but sebis is an
experienced shooter yeah
Davis will oh yes good because it's a
lot somewhere there it says then versus
the ruse who would win in football game
I think Russia would win yeah Venezuelan
don't it do you have a good team no I'm
not really no I mean Russia don't either
but I'll tell you how [ __ ] our football
team is one of them plays foreverton
sorry Anton
all right
Anton uh I hereby allow you to prevent
Francis from eating tonight in Revenge
mate the revenge is going to be sweet
for us for you it's going to be very
very bitter no no he's gonna absolutely
very acidic like an empty stomach yeah
you look you you keep trolling him you
never know how it's going to end mate no
I do know it's going to win I lived with
him for two years mate I know it's going
to end for me yeah all right mate well
look by the way you know you've got you
guys were talking about the gender stuff
do you know Francis that the guardian
yeah
The Guardian newspaper yeah you're
familiar with it yeah I'm familiar with
it well they've actually worked out yeah
there's quite a lot of people
transitioning who maybe shouldn't be
transitioning really yeah have a look at
this mate
an explosion what is behind the rise and
ghost questioning
their gender identity
as the NHS reviews gender referrals
parents clinicians and young people
reveal the social medical and emotional
challenges they face
by Amelia gentlemen what greatness great
name earlier this year a team of NHS
researchers was asked to investigate why
there has been such a huge right a huge
rise excuse me in the number of
adolescent biological goals seeking
referrals to gender clinics the figures
alone do seem remarkable or really
you've worked us out now have you we've
been banging on about it for years
anyway according to a study commissioned
by NHS England 10 years ago there were
just under 250 referrals most of them
boys to the gender identity development
service gids run by the Tavistock and
Portman NHS Foundation trust in London
last year there were more than 5 000
which was twice a number in the previous
year and the largest group about
two-thirds now consisted of birth
registered females first presenting in
adolescence were gender related distress
the report said uh the review team is
looking into the causes behind the
considerable increase in the number of
referrals and the changing case mix but
is not expected to publish any findings
until next year yeah keep going
meanwhile clinicians and parents are
trying to make sense of it themselves
over recent months the guardian has
interviewed 11 parents of gender
questioning adolescent biological girls
some of whom have transitioned to become
trans boys and six pediatricians and
child psychiatrists to discuss their
views and experiences for many of them
it has been a difficult and emotionally
draining time their testimony reflects a
lack of consensus within the medical
profession about how best to proceed if
a child experiences gender dysphoria and
in turn how this confusion contributes
to the central dilemma faced by
concerned parents how should they
support their child during what may be
the most challenging period of their
lives do they accept them changing their
name gender and pronouns at home and in
school and investigating medical options
or should they try to help their child
to accept their natal sex while some
parents said they had embraced their
child's decision and welcomed the
societal changes that had made this step
possible others felt confused by their
child's desire to become a different sex
wow really several parents said they had
been relaxed when their daughters
initially began identifying as
non-binary but became uneasy when they
said they wanted to say purely puberty
blockers or cross-sex hormones and began
binding their breasts yeah a whole bunch
of bigots mate yeah I mean so I'll be on
I might feel a bit uneasy if my daughter
decided to take puberty blocks stop
being racist man yeah that is true some
spoke of their anxiety and uncertainty
about how to respond particularly when
the child was unhappy the mother of one
girl who came out as trans at the age of
12 said it was very difficult to
describe the feeling of being a parent
of a trans identified child this mother
feared they were heading towards medical
intervention that might prove
unnecessary as she got older we had less
control living with that fear is one of
the toughest experiences I've had a
child who recently started University
now describes herself as non-binary and
uses a general Nutri gender-neutral name
but is happy to refer be referred to as
she and is no longer seeking medical
treatment so basically she grew out of
it like most kids do the uncertainty
parents felt was compounded by the
highly polarized debate within the NHS
politics and the media about how parents
and professionals should respond to
children who Express distress about
their gender we were terrified of being
accused of being bigoted said the woman
who asked to remain anonymous to protect
her child's here's the thing that I have
a problem with that right
you were terrified of being accused of
being bigoted you were so terrified that
you were prepared to put your child's
long-term health and happiness on the
line because you were worried about some
Authority nasty words that people were
going to say to you
it's crazy but anyway Francis the
guardian's woken up to the fact that
this is actually an issue yeah I'd
imagine quite a few of us feel quite
Vindicated at this point and in
particular ourselves but also Suzanne
Moore
lots and lots and lots of people by the
way uh the woman who used to run I think
ebl has just put something in the chat
about how the woman who used to run uh
mermaids has just resigned she's a green
well they they sued the LGB Alliance
yeah
um and it ended very badly and I think
it's kind of gone badly from there
anyway progress guys yep things are
looking up if the guardian is concerned
about these issues perfect Anton let's
catch up on on the super chats that
we've got going on as well old monkey
bones were the five euros uh it says by
the prediction of sabuccio England nil
USA nil due to ball being lost on the
under the fridge freezer thanks on
Monday that's it oh and by the way on
locals
let's get it sorry that's not it
we got on my super chat okay cool and
then we'll go okay Frank poof love how
the guardian is super concerned about
girls transitioning to be boys but not
good boys wanting to be girls I mean who
wouldn't want to do that well the future
is female shut up shut your mouth Frank
Booth yep so online course what we do
before every rule is we put a post up
where you can suggest the topics that
you want discussed this is
an opportunity only available on our
locals it's seven bucks a month you get
incredible content you get the chance to
ask God get a site Dr J battacharya
questions that you've always want
answered you've got access to an
incredible Community where you can share
memes you've also got the chance to
interact with us we are always on there
with do a bit of back and forth you can
be like super Ness who actually wanted
us to talk about the Crusaders questions
at the very start so if you want
to become part of the music Community if
you want to influence what it is that we
talk about join locals only seven bucks
a month
uh Joseph Eason sorry so how do you know
me it could have been a 35
000 certificate but it's not he says I
am excited to see you doing keto FF I
hope you will Embrace The Swinging her
lifestyle kettlebells are amazing
fitness equipment
Tony you're a fan of the Kettlebell
aren't you yeah loves it yeah if Francis
tried to use a kettlebell I think some
of his joints would fall out yeah they
would like mine yeah uh John with the
two quizzes I Miss Shawna McDowell where
are you where are you where are you sure
that's it Shawna McDonald is someone he
is used to contribute to the to the
Roars a lot yeah and uh she's very
active on locals as well yeah she's
great all right mate you had some videos
you wanted to talk about as well did you
yes we did there is a brilliant video uh
from former guest Mr Ryan long it is a
very very funny video and here we go
Anton take it away
we have no audio on that one um we've
got audio problems tonight mate yeah
okay
so there we go okay well we have no
audio
sorry about that guys don't know what
happened there uh we'll get it sorted
out Francis do we have a video with
audio that we wanted to talk about yeah
uh do we have a audio with a video that
we wanted to talk about yes we do indeed
let's talk about
I'll tell you what let's talk about this
story number 20 how about actually
number 18 please Anton and this reminds
me of a brilliant interview that we did
with the wonderful critical Drinker and
it's actually talking about a lot of the
issues that we spoke about in that
interview here it is it's Anthony Mackey
the evolution of the business has gone
to like there are no movie stars anymore
like Anthony Mackey isn't a movie star
the Falcon is a movie star
and that's what's weird it used to be
with Tom Cruise and Will Smith and
Stallone and Schwarzenegger when you
went to the movies you went to go see
the Stallone movie you went to go see
the Schwarzenegger movie now you go see
X-Men
so the the evolution of the superhero
has meant the death of the movie star
and that's the fear now because you're
now making movies for 16 year olds and
China
and that's it
it's an interesting point I I think
um the mass customization of everything
also has a big role to play like
everybody can watch exactly the type of
movie or Netflix series or whatever that
they want which means that there are
fewer overarching people who like map
across different groups of people I
think that's probably a big part of it
as well but yeah I mean I really
basically don't I used to love the
cinema I used to go every week I had one
of those unlimited Cinema cards and
everything I haven't been to the cinema
for years man literally years and I
think that's a very very real problem
because like you said you know
nowadays everything is in a niche
everybody has their niche of what they
enjoy but
the days of like you know remember we
were talking about this with critical
Drinker the days of like an Arnold
Schwarzenegger movie the days of the
movie star are gone and it's now
everything just seems to be a comic book
movie and look I've got no problem with
a comic book movie but when it seems to
be that everything is a comic book movie
that just shows that
in many ways we've lost our ability to
be creative yeah as we've silenced
artists in our society so you've got
people you know if you think about some
of the greatest movies they're putting
forward ideas it could be transgressive
but we don't do that anymore yeah
because we don't want to alienate people
and we certainly don't know foreign
markets like China so what we do is we
produce
comic book movies that are never going
to alienate these types of markets yep
absolutely on a slightly different note
Francis Maximilian Center five pound
PayPal says Francis would last in prison
for a very long time good he says the
inmates would adjust the Gap in his fart
valve valve on the first night fantastic
Francis do you know who would never
adjust your fart valve on the first
night
everybody
indeed expressvpn is a VPN that is
recommended by trigonometry it is
absolutely fantastic when you're the
only one we advertise anymore exactly
not because they told us not to anyway
it is absolutely brilliant it's a VPN
that just works it is indeed go to
expressvp uh vpn.com trigger for three
months free with a 12-month plan so you
buy a 12 month plan and you get 15
months uh as a bonus because you're a
trigonometry fan check them out they're
the only VPN we recommend expressvpn is
the VPN for you and like we say they
will not do anything to your valve
exactly so let's talk about that should
we talk about let's I'll tell you what
we can talk about let's talk about a
good news story let's talk about number
10. okay let's do it
and Minecraft in the chat says gotta say
expressvpn is actually good it is and by
the way the game's kicking off in four
minutes so we'll do this and then we
will wrap up the show tourists mobbed
after climbing sacred Mayan pyramid in
Mexico okay yeah
uh the more impairments are famed for
their hieroglyphs depicting myths and
scenes of ritualistic sacrifice the
Temple of kokulkan in Mexico became a
site of religious realistic sorry
ritualistic humiliation
after a tourist was doused with water
and booed for scaling the sacred
Monument climbing the steps of the
79-foot structure at the Chichen Itza
archaeological site is prohibited in a
video which has been viewed more than
three and a half million times on Tick
Tock a woman is seen posing at the top
of the pyramid also known as known as El
Castillo before a man appears to beckon
her away the tourists who may have
misunderstood angry cries as cheers
danced and wait for her and onlookers
below as she made her way back down only
to be greeted by cries of jail a jail
and sacrifice sat [ __ ] up they wanted
them to carve a heart out yeah Jesus
Christ uh the woman had to be ushered
through the angry mob while some threw
water bottles at her head [ __ ] hell
social media eunices were not impressed
by the display there are human remains
inside inside there inside dancing on
top of a grave the disrespect one said
another person commented imagine if
someone climbed up on the altar in a
cathedral and did a rude dance this
pyramid is sacred and that's what she
did it was not the first time a tourist
has provoked anger for trespassing on
the UNESCO world heritage site a woman
was filmed climbing the monument before
being escorted Away by police in January
last year there it is there she is doing
a little dance in front of everybody
uh tourists who uh were banned from
climbing the 91 steps of the pyramid in
2008 because of conservation and safety
concerns uh an 80 year old American
woman fell to her death in 2006 or
two-thirds of the way up I'm glad you
find that funny mate just laughed
halfway through but it's kind of like
well that was was a purpose of it wasn't
it
well so there's some 80 year old
American a millennium 500 years later or
whatever yeah sort of built some time
between the 8th and 12th centuries by
the pre-columbian Maya civilization El
Castillo was a temple to The Feathered
Serpent God kukul Khan twice a year at
the spring and Autumn equinoxes the
Setting Sun creates the illusion of a
snake crawling down the pyramid's facade
the Mexican Institute of anthropology in
history said that the monument had not
been damaged by the most recent incident
there you got me how do you feel about
your culture being spent upon yeah I
thought it was just disgrace and I like
the lovely Touch of sacrifice sacrifice
that was good I like it yeah imagine
you're in a foreign country you climb up
the wrong monument and as you come down
there's just a bunch of angry locals
basically demanding someone chops your
head off
yeah and she sees
these are people [ __ ] shouting she's
like
it's what they celebrate and then they
do she does a little dance
there we go Anton do we have anything we
need to catch up on very good well uh
we'll leave you this box head uh says
2-1 to the USA my octopus says
and we can only hope that his octopus is
not in fact his genitals yep uh ladies
oh we've got one chaotic neutral with
the two says England so don't forget my
Indian accent okay England
bloody bastard England
why the Indian not in the World Cup
England whenever you go you [ __ ] things
up
all right guys thank you so much for
joining us tonight we are back tomorrow
at the usual time 7 P.M enjoy yourself
tonight whether you're American and
you're going to enjoy Thanksgiving and
losing five nil or whether you're
English and you're gonna enjoy the game
take care have a great one we'll see you
tomorrow
hey Francis do you want to protect your
privacy cool so I do now that I'm an
International Celebrity who's appeared
on hit shows like The Joe Rogan
Experience I have to protect myself from
vicious people looking to tear me down
on the Michael Jackson of the internet
not the celebrity I would have gone for
but trust is important when picking a
VPN I don't trust anyone after she left
me she took everything Francis remember
what your lawyer said good point you can
trust expressvpn because they don't sell
your data to advertisers they've even
created software called trusted server
that means they can't store any data at
all expressvpn uses lightweight a VPN
protocol that makes user speeds faster
than ever expressvpn is now blazingly
fast you can watch HD videos with zero
buffering thousands of pounds in legal
fees the great thing about expressvpn is
that you don't need any technical skills
to set up just like Francis fire up the
app and it's one button to connect One
Tap on a button was all it needed for my
entire life to disintegrate
loads of people are saying that
expressvpn is the best VPN there is
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn as
the number one VPN in the world go on
Francis protect yourself with
expressvpn use or link
expressvpn.com trigger today and get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's
expressvpn.com trigger visit
expressvpn.com trigger to learn more she
took everything